qui arrive à leur communauté le choc est
immense c'est difficile parce qu'on
connaît tout le monde c'est les gens qui
sont décédés les gens qui sont impliqués
on connaît tout le monde
cet homme a évité de justesse la
camionnette qui a foncé sur plusieurs
piétons il sortait tout juste de chez le
dentiste il a entendu un bruit une
fraction de seconde un monsieur à côté
de moi là il y a pas eu la chance que
j'ai eu de
je me suis extirpé j'ai juste sauté le
bas du trottoir
c'est une fraction de seconde j'ai eu le
temps juste le temps de sauter j'ai
sauté tout le monde tout le monde était
ce trottoir visiblement toujours ébranlé
Ken Moro nous raconte qu'il a essayé
d'aider des enfants moi j'ai essayé de
la petite fille et puis petit garçon je
critique garçon dans mes bras j'ai
détaché la petite fille de sa poussette
une madame qui l'a pris dans ses bras ce
garçon a même plus de bottes son chapeau
David Morin et lui aussi toujours secoué
parce qu'il a vu il est arrivé par
hasard juste après l'attaque au camion
faire ça c'est des enquêteurs tentent de
reconstituer la scène du drame pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé le geste
était intentionnel selon la Sûreté du
Québec la camionnette à heurté des
piétons puis afoncer sur d'autres
personnes un peu plus loin deux hommes
sont morts Gérald Charest 65 ans et Jean
Lafrenière 73 ans si vous avez besoin
n'hésitez pas demain après-demain la
semaine prochaine
composer le 8 heures si on veut pour
avoir de l'aide il y a quelqu'un qui va
vous répondre merci aux gens de me
couper à présent déjà dans ma têteiens
qui vont se relever ensemble la tragédie
a résonné partout au pays les réactions
sont nombreuses dans la classe politique
aussi le ministre de la Sécurité
publique est allé voir la scène
ah ok je vais offrir mes pensées les
plus sincères mais sympathie aux
familles éprouvées la communauté
d'amkoui on est face à ces fatalités on
cherche des moyens et cette folie
meurtrière c'est
un drame épouvantable qui touche la
matapaisa en plein cœur de son
centre-ville à me trouver la matapedia
c'est une communauté qui pleure qui
cherche à comprendre l'Église catholique
de Annequin invite les gens à se
recueillir à l'église et à y déposer
fleur et peluche puis quand on a vu
aujourd'hui qu'on pouvait venir porter
des fleurs pour les personnes les
enfants ont dit maman faut y aller parce
qu'il y a du monde qui sont morts les
cloches de l'église vont sonner tous les
jours jusqu'à vendredi heure du drame et
ce vendredi soir il y aura une messe
pour permettre à la communauté de se
recueillir et penser ses plaies